so this law which seems to be really
focused on the subways Chipotle's of the
market now affects your your most
well-trained highly experienced chefs
mastered their craft I've never had any
issue and have been using their hands
for thirty years now they you know this
really throws him for a loop here in Los
Angeles plastic bags are a big no-no the
plastic gloves will they get the stamp
of approval the cognitive dissonance
you're experiencing is all thanks to
changes in the California food retail
code which now requires all food service
employees to wear gloves when handling
ready-to-eat foods this includes steak
sushi bread fruit and even your tasty
cocktail many other states have similar
laws but the new code caught many
california-based companies and
independent chefs by surprise sparking a
backlash in the food community officials
say it's on the name of promoting
cleanliness but will the new law really
do anything to protect our health los
angeles-based attorney Jordan Bernstein
of Michael Minh and Robinson counsel
some of California's top chefs and
eateries he recently sat down with
reason to discuss the unintended
consequences of the new law the previous
law dis encouraged bare hand contact
with food unless you were really
complying with the laws regarding
washing of your hands so you were
allowed to have bare hand contact with
food as long as you were really paying
attention to keeping your hands clean
and really abiding by all the other
health and safety regulations within a
kitchen setting the big issue is the
sushi chef in LA or across the country
that's really you know you've never seen
really a sushi chef preparing your your
rolls or your sushi pieces with gloves
on so they've always been you know with
their bare hands so that's that's really
one of the big consequences that sushi
chefs will now have to wear gloves also
recently there's been a big hell of
about bartenders having to wear gloves
and they are often handling lemon or
fruit and oranges everything that
they're doing all the curries
concoctions that are out there
everybody's trying to you know make the
newest drink the bartenders are gonna be
back there wearing gloves you advise a
lot of these restaurant chairs and chefs
what kind of questions are you getting
from them about this law one is how do
we really comply with it and what's the
expense that could be associated with
because you know a big kitchen that has
30 40 people in it just think about it
through the course of one day could go
through hundreds if not thousands
actually not hundreds probably thousands
of clubs so well you might think oh it's
just a pair of latex or plastic gloves
now we're talking boxes of gloves so
that's a really you know it could be an
expense the other issue is how can we
get an exemption problem is California
really hasn't told you how you can get
that exemption and it injures reading
the statute itself it's a pretty onerous
process or compliance procedure to get
the to become exempt from the haul let
me ask was there any sort of impetus for
this law because it seems like he said
you know there have been chefs that I've
been working with food for almost 30
years why I have this law now I mean the
impetus is pretty much the same with all
these safety regulations they want to
prevent foodborne illness right but I
would say most foodborne illness comes
either from the source of the food
potentially the meat or the vegetable
already has it on the product and it's a
matter of cleaning the product not
necessarily someone's hands some of the
notable chefs in LA at least have said
there's a possibility of that wearing
gloves really won't have the intended
effect because people will use it as a
sort of a false sense of security and
that their hands are clean and they they
won't actually wash their hands they'll
just put on gloves we contacted several
chefs to get their take and they were
all afraid to kind of open up because
they're afraid of getting the shakedown
from the Health Department and I thought
it was interesting because then how do
you organize a movement to get rid of
the silly law when shot that seems chefs
are really afraid about speaking out
about well I yesterday actually I just
saw if you go to I believe it's change
dot org they the bartenders in
California have gotten together and they
put up a ballot and you sign it and
they're hoping to get a certain number
of signatures and hopefully there it
could translate into something to get
them exempt bartenders that is exempt
from the law hopefully there could be
something similar for certain businesses
within the industry certain restaurant
businesses how long is it before state
of California tells us we have to wear
gloves at home when we're preparing food
that would be very interesting if they
step into your house and told you what
to do but you know it never stops the
legislature from doing so before you
start trashing your plastic box or
kitchen gloves there is some good news
the California Restaurant Association is
working with the state legislature to
improve the law before it fully goes
into effect maybe they can convince
Sacramento bureaucrats that having a
cookie cutter approach to food safety
has no place in any kitchen